everyone I'm the Aguilar coming to you
live from comic-con and Ichi sweet with
the Stars there is what do you want
really no I get really hot okay I just
got really high blood pressure so
sometimes I overheat it's the pressure
of not wanting to say spoilers not
actually when we do work and we're in
summer like they'll put ice vests all
over me but they do yeah they attach ice
packs to it so yeah we were just saying
this is the very first time that I've
interviewed you guys at comic-con when
we're in the middle of a season so now
you could actually say things yeah
this season is particularly crazy we've
got new friends new foes a new place
where everyone wants to live what are
you guys been thinking about this year
what have we been thinking a lot it's
like it's been a really different season
I mean it you know what six years later
and some you know we haven't like all
the dynamics of check it's just my ears
are like ringing and I'm just sweating
that's all I can say that's what I've
been thinking about him yeah it's like
it's a really it's a turbulent season
and you know a lot of friends have
become foes and back again and yeah and
Clark is a mom now yeah there's a mom
ish very protective yes
which has been really fun now that
Maddie has the flame in her and that so
many people are starting to really view
her as a commander how do you think
Clark's gonna react to that not well
mostly because you know I mean there's a
lot of stuff in there like that relates
to Alexis like you know what happened to
Lex I'm being like having that burden
put on a child and you know as she does
she doesn't want that for her
so it's not it's not great but hopefully
she'll accept it well it was interesting
to see in that one scene that you know
Clark did acknowledge that LexA is now
somewhat inside of Maddie that she can
now tap into that subconscious do you
think that we're gonna see you guys
explore that concept a little bit more
and talk about it was that kind of our
moment for the season I'm actually
trying to remember we shot it so long
ago but no I think it's I'm it's a
pretty constant theme you know and it's
good to acknowledge you know but one
thing I was wondering like here we going
okay Lex's inside Maddie's head then was
it somebody else's consciousness that
was inside Lex's head yeah if it's gonna
go all 13 before her there's like no now
that is Maddie still an individual or
she just said you know accumulation
about 14 people
so was LexA just an accumulation of 13
people do you know her name if you keep
going through that lineage just like
well where does it stop it can't just be
LexA it's gonna be Becca a whole bunch
of them yeah but I think it's more that
they like I woke up for that you know
that I adore adore Bellamy and I love
Octavia but I gotta say your on-screen
sisters kinda losing it this year kind
of I think she's like yeah next episode
is called the [ __ ] no that might you
might get some sort of insight yes
hopefully are we gonna be getting like a
flashback as to what exactly was
happening in the bunker and how she kind
of became who she is we're gonna know a
lot more about the docum yeah yeah
definitely safe to say whether that like
actually I mean I don't want to say
anything anything really with it like
just for them yeah but it's it's funny
when do you do flashbacks and stuff alia
audience obviously get you know an
insight into what happened but it
doesn't necessarily mean that the
characters did you know like Bellamy No
is that about yeah yeah what's you know
what happening in the [ __ ] yeah well
well because six years have passed and
while Clark was alone she kept making
those radio calls every single day up to
kind of just whoever was out there but
specifically to Bellamy very sad
are we she needed to talk to someone are
we gonna see Bellamy and Clarke kind of
acknowledged the fact that for six years
she was trying to reach out to him how
many calls she made to Bellamy it's two
thousand one hundred and ninety-nine
times that's a long a miss Cole's bro
there's a lot of missed calls but now
that W Bay's iron by 18 T you could get
that for real cheap yeah talking on the
phone yeah they say what she's looking
ahead as we approach the end of this
season yes oh I mean there's a really
emotional ending actually this season
that yeah I think we both really excited
for people yeah I mean it's actually
yeah is there because you know we were
just talking about the bull our fans are
so passionate mm-hmm they care so much
about your two characters and maybe want
them maybe kind of sort of one day to be
together
yes should they still hold out hope even
though Bellamy is kind of tied up with
someone and clerks in mom mode well the
thing is we don't ever know oh good yeah
we don't we know like which sort we know
I'm really I'm growing this interview
I'm sorry hot I'm good I'm good I guess
so yeah I mean I don't know like it's a
really tricky one for us dance up yeah
we never know episode yep so what what's
gonna happen yeah all right well just
lastly how would you describe this
season finale in one word emotional I
knew I was gonna say that too I yeah
right heartbreaking oh okay yeah thank
you guys so much for sitting down and
shadowing me thank you
I'm sorry I'm so sorry I'm sorry guys
we'll do it will do yeah everybody says
we'll do a makeover